[Musique]
bonjour louis daniel berten je me
souviens ces deux présidents de chambre
d'agriculture certainement très excité à
quelques jours du salon de la profession
à la porte de versailles mais c'est
aussi un président de chambre consulaire
inquiet après les remous de ces derniers
jours autour de la filière viande
monsieur bertheaume nous n'avons eu
cesse de ressasser des restructurations
tour d'une filière à fort potentiel avec
des résultats probants mais finalement
il y a un doute
après les propos d' alfred marie-jeanne
sur matti vial et sur la rive
comment vivez-vous tout cela nous vivons
ça très mal au sein de la profession
puisque nous avons un secteur végétal
qui est complètement désorganisée avec
la disparition de la secrètement et puis
maintenant c'est la filière viande qui
apparemment était assez stabilisé qui
pose pas de difficulté et donc la
chambre d'agriculture qui a reçu un
ensemble des partenaires dans ce dossier
là nous avons aussi m'a dit viens nous
avons reçu le nouveau président de
l'amif nous avons reçu également est
aussi plus de la codem de cool avons eu
assez de tic là nous avons reçu des
coopératives la sq a quand même fait
beau nous avons aussi tous les
partenaires pour essayer de faire un
petit point tout ça nous avons ça fait
deux ou trois ans que nous nous avons
que ça vieux de la récession c'est
vraiment vraiment si ennuyeux parce que
nous oublions et les autres d
organisation et de l'oubli que
l'essentiel c'est quand même le
producteur c'est quand même l'éleveur
essais ils sont là pour permettre à
l'éleveur de vivre de son métier
des accusations très clair de la part du
conseil exécutif avec alfred
marie-jeanne parlant de ces règles a bis
donc opacité détournement de fonds
publics c'est ce qu'il dit alors y'a des
choses
nous avons été logés la la daf qui les
fonds publics pour pour le col de l'état
qui nous dit qu'il ya bien la cargaison
fait des comptoirs nous avons été gema
divers qui nous dit mais non le co2 sans
son public nous avons été à plusieurs
reprises
auditionné veut en tout cas contrôler y
à rien et donc les accusations que porte
le président a cité m je dis qu'il faut
effectivement civile pense qu'il ya des
malversations
il faut qu'ils portaient précisons qu'on
puisse et l'entrée dans le fond de ce
dossier là précise on doit non seulement
voir la gestion des fonds d'aidé des
fonds des fonds mais également la la
gestion même de ces deux structures il
faut le préciser renaud gaudeul qui le
procureur de la république a écrit à
l'exécutif justement pour avoir d'autres
éléments
car il ya eu des contrôles vous l'avez
vrai de dire qu'ils n'ont rien donné à
ce jour selon lui on parle quand même de
tonnes de viande comestibles julie
boulet au centre de valorisation
organique du robert seulement là aussi
moi j'ai interrogé la direction de
l'agriculture puisque j'ai entendu ça
qui me dit maintenant il ya eu des
déchets fait les choses ont été
contrôlés également donc là aussi si on
a des éléments comme ça il faut le mari
fait pour la profession c'est ça le
problème le point c'est que une fois
qu'on sort des des dossiers comme ça le
mal est fait
d'ailleurs à l'époque j'avais dit ben on
est en train de faire du buzz avec un
sujet qui n'a qu'une qu'il ne l'était
pas donc même si je parle pas de buzz je
dis que si on a des éléments il faut les
mettre aux beaux jours il faut les
mettre dans les mains de la justice et
on ne peut pas continuer dans ce thème
dans cet esprit de de dénonciation et on
n'a pas d'éléments et lâchant de
l'agriculture n'a aucun élément pour
pouvoir dire que c'est vrai où
s'épanouit la filière viande c'était bel
et bien structuré en rap on peut
rappeler ce qui était faux cours des
dernières années notamment la création
de matty vial qui était sur le papier
une vraie volonté politique de
promouvoir ce secteur d'activité ne
serait ce qu en allant sur le site le
portail électronique de demain divialle
c'est très joli
ce qu'on voit absolument alors faut se
rappeler aussi que manivelle est né un
peu une idée de la chambre d'agriculture
2007 quand quand janot 107,9 j'avais
demandé aux aux coopératives de faire un
effort de mutualisation parce que
rendront on avait plutôt de deux copines
qui n'arrivait pas à vivre et donc nous
avons demandé de faire une mutualisation
deux directions en particulier qui est l
encadrement des agriculteurs mais
également puisque c'est eux qui ont la
responsabilité de l'encadrement de leurs
de leurs adhérents mais également au
niveau de la commercialisation
ils ont été beaucoup plus loin ils ont
fait d'abord une union ensuite une
fusion qui a donné m'a dit viens tous
les partis c'est 2010 et s'est offert un
seau d'eau sont aujourd'hui du boeuf
absolue la main du port et de la
volaille absolument c'était pas bien
quand ça n'est pas l'idée de la chambre
d'agriculture je pense qu'on a été très
vite et très loin mais n'empêche que et
il fallait effectivement qu'on
restructure ses coûts de changement m'a
dit vial démontre que l a des résultats
ce que je dis au niveau de la joue la
grippe tue c'est que ces résultats-là
doit profiter aux agriculteurs aux
éleveurs et nouvelles gouvernances vous
appelez une nouvelle gouvernance de la
filière viande il fallait écarter ce
parc qui sont là n'auront pas une
matière que la sixième la chambre
d'agriculture depuis très longtemps dit
que on a confié uniquement aux
organisations économiques pas uniquement
au niveau de la viande au niveau de la
production générale et les coopératives
au niveau des filières végétales c'est
pareil on a confié les temps a confié
uniquement aux organisations économiques
le soin de labellisation économique et
les coopératives ne peut pas rembourser
les coopératives et donc si on n'est pas
dans une coopérative
on est pris au sérieux comme un
gouvernement on n'a pas d'être on n'a
rien nous ce que nous disons c'est qu'il
faut une nouvelle gouvernance qui est
une nouvelle cohérence des politiques
publiques qui sont dirigés en
destination des agriculteurs et là on
commence à sentir la terre ce moment
chez vous oui parce que parce que vous
avez été écarté vous chambre que la
chance que les syndicats professionnels
ont été avérés bien sûr bien sûr parce
que c'est pas nous n'avons plus droit à
rien même quand il faut faire de
l'encadrement pour les agriculteurs le
diadème qui gère les fonds à ce niveau
là nous dit mais vous n'êtes pas
éligibles donc les agriculteurs se
plaignent sur le terrain parce qu'ils
ont pas de l'encadrement technique
suffisant et nous au niveau de la
chambre d'agriculture avons pas de
moyens pour faire cet accablement là
donc nous disons qu'il faut voir un peu
les choses
il faut faire en sorte que les bailleurs
de fonds
ky kiske qui financent l'agriculture est
qui qui sont porteurs de politiques
publiques que ce soit l'état qui gère
également les fonds européens que ce
soit la collectivité qui maintenant j
offre des fonds européens également
il faut que ces structures à ces deux
pôles la semaine en somme avec l'action
d'amr youtube pour définir le
l'orientation qu'on doit donner à notre
agriculture parce que la chan et
l'expertisé du monde agricole
oui mais on a beaucoup entendu les
agriculteurs à un certainement dire
qu'il fallait se mettra semble plus
exempt plus fort la coopérative ont
entendu ces mêmes agriculteurs se
plaindre du fonctionnement des
coopératives est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
peut faire mieux et qui doit être le
garant de meilleur fonctionnement c'est
la ctm c'est l'état c'est la chambre
consulaire c'est le sait tous c'est
justement cette gouvernance là que non
que nous appelons de nos voeux
mais kelly doit malras bridoire baril
qui doit faire en sorte que
effectivement les coopératives
fonctionne mieux et alors il ya plein de
choses à faire derrière il ya la
formation des hommes et il ya plein de
choses mais en tout cas il faut que dès
le départ on puisse organiser ça il faut
il faut que ceux qui qui qui pays soient
en mesure en concertation de décider de
ce qui doit se passer c'est pas que la
collectivité qui doit donner des idées
des dd on life défilé vers la
collectivité pour donner deux coups
demander des subventions par six voix là
et puis de l'autre côté l'état qui fait
ce qu'elle veut comme elle veut sans
concertation et puis que personne ne
veut me voir comment on va qu'est ce
qu'on va faire avec notre avis que vous
évoquez adore dans le communiqué suite à
la ferme a dit vial
vous évoquez une entière une orientation
partager des pratiques transparente les
mesures de soutien accessible à tous ce
sont des mots choisis qui on te sens
tout cela ce n'est pas encore la carrure
non non et notamment quand je dis que la
politique publique aussi doit aller en
direction de l'ensemble des agriculteurs
quand je rigole
c'est un petit abidjan nous étions sur
le terrain le bureau de la chaume était
sur le terrain nous avons des
agriculteurs qui quelquefois non non non
le nomade aide et donc nous disons que
les keys a écarté vous chambres
consulaires qui a décidé d'écarter les
syndicats professionnels non mais c'est
la politique qui est menée en ce moment
qui nous qui nous et quand naturellement
de cette politique est bien également
déjà les menées par l'état et les mener
quand vous avez des coopératives qui
défilent le responsable c'est l'état ben
y'a pas que l'état j'ai dit il faut
qu'il y ait une cohérence dans les
politiques publiques qui sont menées
époux qui est cohérent s'il faut que les
gens se retrouvent et c'est ça c'est
dans cet état d'esprit que la martinique
s'apprête à partir du dernier bertone à
paris sera la semaine prochaine au salon
de l'agriculture qui commencera à partir
du 25 de ce mois la délégation combien
de personnes quelles filières alors bon
la délégation de la chambre
d'agriculture nous devons être cinq ou
six personnes qui partent qu'ils pardon
uniquement volet salon sur le compte de
la chambre d'agriculture mais nous avons
aussi à côté beaucoup d'élus de chant
qui part avec d'autres organisations et
qui seront présents sur le salon
mais c'est quand même une bonne
délégation de martiniquais de
l'agriculture à s'envoler
ça vaut le coup d'y aller absolument je
crois que le le sens de la griffe douce
et plus de 700 milles a fait près de 700
mille visiteurs chaque année et on
estime que 60 % de ses visiteurs vont
sur le stand où les l'espace outre-mer
et est donc une bonne partie visiteurs
on y va surtout pour vendre la
destination martinique ou bien pour
faire valoir notre savoir faire dans
certains de ses leaders comme le miel
par exemple nous y allons vous présenter
ce que nous faisons au niveau de la
matinée donc nous présenterons notre
agriculture a lonesome nous avons à côté
de nous aussi quelques grands grands
secteurs la banane la can c'est le web
sont présents sur le stand le melon ils
ont raison ils ont leur sens et non
parce que nous reconnaissons la chambre
d'agriculture le haut représentant et
donc nous représenteront l'ensemble de
la profession
donc ça c'est une pression une deuxième
chose c'est que nous nous nous essayons
en présentant nos productions présente
en nous nos produits montrer ce que la
marque ne fait pas seulement de la
banane pas seulement du rhum mais nous
avons un navire ou diversifier il faut
le présenter
et c'est cette année comme ça fait deux
ou trois ans que nous que nous allons il
ya le parc naturel qui sera présent ce
que nous avons un stand institutionnel
où nous avons trois partenaires qui sont
qui sont là c'est c
le comité martiniquais du tourisme et le
parc naturel comme thématique 12 parce
que beaucoup de gens qui viennent sur le
stand envie de connaître la destination
à faire voir la destination martinique
et donc c'est important de représenter
sa d'ailleurs ce que nous estimons c'est
que lorsque les gens viennent chez nous
bien il faut qu'il puisse aussi venu
pour consommer nos productions ici
déguster vraie question de miel de glace
lieu dans le cadre de la sortie que nous
avons eus sous le terrain nous avons été
dans un restaurant d'un autocar bien où
nous avons nous faisons travailler avec
ce responsable qui met en valeur la
pollution locale l on a mangé du mouton
martin tournoi vous tomberez nous nous
trouvons que nous et ce monsieur nous
dit que ben je fais près de 700000 euros
de chiffre d'affaires avec la production
agricole et ça c'est important
et tout ce que nous avons vraiment
génial c'était de la production locale
et donc ça c'est important que le tous
vient il faut absolument que le touriste
découvre une production ici et donc il
faut qu'on puisse leur faire connaître
et puis nous avons beaucoup d'animations
aussi disons qu'ils sont faits
merci beaucoup lui daniel bertin
président de la chambre d'agriculture le
sens de la culture ce sera la semaine
prochaine à paris merci bonne journée
bien
[Musique]